foreign
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Grant Gustin and I'm
Lucy Hale and we start in buzzfeed's
latest rom-com with some very cute doggy
cup Stars which is why we are going to
take a quiz to find out what doggy read
we are we are let's do this let's do it
all right how would your closest friends
describe you the options are fabulous
loyal hilarious tall goofy playful
confident stubborn and adorable and so
we can only pick one
this is your closest friends well no one
ever in the history of my life has
called me tall so that's out for me I'm
gonna go stubborn for me I'm so
self-deprecating you would choose the
like quote-unquote worse no that's just
I'm stubborn I'm gonna go with either
hilarious or adorable
I think you should go tall okay or or
loyal I'm gonna go with loyal because I
am and I feel like my friends would say
that oh this is a good one which dish
would you bring to
which dish would you bring to a potluck
okay potato salad mac and cheese I love
deviled eggs so much you're from
Virginia I am you're fantastic yeah yeah
I think you need help garlic bread
coleslaw brownies green bean casserole
cupcakes wine I'd bring wine that's like
the easy option though like everyone
doesn't know what to bring so they're
like oh let's bring it yeah so but you
know what I'm gonna bring because it
reminds me of my grandmother would you
actually bring this though yes because
they're really easy to make too don't
ask me what's in it because I don't
actually know but I know it's like a
couple of ingredients deviled eggs so
you've made them before yes okay
a staple in my in my outsole actually
okay what's your favorite holiday
Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween Easter
Fourth of July Boxing Day St Patrick's
Day your birthday I hate all holidays
you probably will choose that one no I'm
not gonna just like choose the negative
ones I was I used to really think I'd be
really nervous about like I need to eat
like I would do you were nervous because
you felt like you needed yeah I used to
put a lot of pressure on myself between
like ages of eight and eleven I threw up
every Thanksgiving that's so graphic
from anxiety so you're choosing box
again I might choose my birthday but I I
think I'm gonna go with Christmas okay
I'm gonna go Thanksgiving because
gratitude food etc etc okay pick a
condiment this is if there are a few
things you should know about me Grant do
you want me I love dogs and I love
condiments this is going to be really
challenging okay ketchup Mayo relish
you're doing this thing where you just
suddenly stop and you think I'm supposed
to dance
like Sriracha pesto Ranch BBQ sauce soy
sauce
yeah I've never said that before I just
wanted to see how thank you okay I know
what mine is and it's Ranch hands down
that is crazy that's not crazy
I actually love ranch and you want to
hear something really disgusting about
me sure
I'm the person that
will strong and ask for a second Branch
yeah
um I'm gonna go with soy sauce
you're so weird
I like adding soy sauce to
your eggs rice like all dishes with rice
essentially doesn't matter what type of
dish it is I like adding stores okay if
you won the lottery what's the first
thing you would buy a big house a fancy
car plane tickets
close new phone shoes I would donate it
all I would pay off loans or debt I
would save it all that had an
exclamation point I would save it all
I would say plane tickets to go travel
get the hell out of here I probably a
car like I love I love cars
I don't really know a lot about them but
I love them okay and finally pick the
ink block that catches your eye okay
wait what am I doing these are images so
it lights up a different part of the
brain
oh my gosh Waits which one like reached
out to you
[Music]
I actually like really disagree with
this and that's why it's so funny I'm a
pug
let's be honest you're a total goofball
you're hilarious and adorable and you
love the spotlight not only that but
your empathetic and thoughtful just look
at those adorable puppy eyes
I'm doing the inflections there there
are punctuations in sentences yes you
tend to be highly emotional but that's
what's so great about you most of that
is pretty good I agree with a lot of
that right with the rundown I don't
think you're a total goofball
but everything else is like
accurate highly emotional
cute yeah okay so I got a Labradoodle
obviously because I'm known for my
intelligence
kindness and cheerful disposition I'm a
self-confident pup who rarely comes
across as aggressive not true there's
nothing you love more than helping
people actually you might love swimming
more
well what are you waiting for jump in do
you agree with mine it says I'm a
self-confident pup who rarely comes
across as aggressive
is that accurate I guess so I don't know
I don't love swimming yeah the swimming
feels random but I don't really know
what am I waiting for I'm gonna yeah
jump in yeah okay that's fun so thanks
for playing along and be sure to check
out our new movie really soon
[Music]
okay we got two good takes